hallo mein name ist nun konnten
helikopter über meine wohnung wir
spielen heute das spiel presse nikita
store das heißt wir fangen einfach mal
an stiehlt ihr wollt abwickelt polyphon
up and downs expected to be stupid
optical solutions terre des hommes seeks
to build the slow as possible for a
decade of use das spiel handelt von
juice nicht dass ich etwas falsches
denkt das spiel doch denke ich was
falsches handeln allerdings nicht von
menschen sondern von früchten oder obst
oder das ist da der unterschied es ist
ein wenig wie sap services heißt wir was
ist wenn ich dagegen klar okay ich hab
schnell angefangen wir müssen quasi
diesen leuten hier ausweichen um damit
das nicht passiert so ich beantworte
jetzt schnell
große story telling als ob ich irgendwas
benötige vom drogerie laden kolonie
trina playstation move your screen ihm
das hier kommen hier
wie kann ich das denn jetzt abschicken
out of georgia asparagus pages okay dann
will ich mal ganz kurz
fresh koop modi multicom wie kann ich es
dem versenden man die gt wie kann ich
denn versenden es geht ein ganzer sex
korrekt lead to boost your shoes ganz
ruhig luca da unten kommt jetzt da
genoss das handy baby moment nicht so
horst eckel baby ok dann macht es doch
jetzt nach ich muss da drauf klicken
danke dass ihr mir das auch mal sagt
jetzt geht's los freunde jetzt werde ich
dieses spiel sowas von auseinander dem
days or die süßen förster gott zum gruße
abo street view bernadette der ok ja man
gut okay wir haben gut aufgefüllt jetzt
warten da kommt es nicht denn am
ostbahnhof infection das scheiße dieser
run wird definitiv länger als ein paar
kilometer
jetzt kommt nämlich auch schon das handy
da ist das handy mal zucchini tradition
oder melamin letzten drei freien
generated aces jetzt ok also perfekt
ausgewichen soll jetzt hier da kommt
dieses komische erdmännchen sorgt
getting ready denn august beinahe
halbieren faction armageddon oder die
rocker ja das nehmen wir das hinein
scheiße das war negativ feeling remote
office edition
try something kenne let's get enough
biergärten
ich würde es nicht wundern wenn gleich
die nachbarn schon an klingeln bei mir
wenn ich hier so laut bin weil das ist
einfach so wieso klopfe ich gegen die
wand so jetzt kommt dieser helikopter
wieder hört ideen so eine scheiße aber
auch jedenfalls kommen wir machen jetzt
noch einen run wo ich einfach wirklich
ich will mir ja direkt ist eine himbeere
in ordnung dass das handy internet
bannern anja pocket eine banane fr
ich hab da nicht drauf geklickt haudegen
apple baute marc erwartet bald jetzt
okay das war richtig des kartoffel
skateboard us-pläne ihr okay dann nehmen
wir dieses projekt ein dummkopf
natürlich bin ich auch deuce jetzt
konzentriere ich mich okay und ich
antworte mit einem zwinkern okay das war
super da kommt das handy auch schon
wieder mal zucchinis reggiano chemie
nachtzug astoria lohkamp isola als ok
das war richtig das ist es so schlimm
ich war schon wieder nicht 100 kilometer
kochtopf
mein gott das nehmen wir das nehmen will
scheiße mit herzinger startup gotham
racing the boss luca das war ein richtig
guter sport zucchinis ready okay dann
schreibe ich kenne texte dafür dass wir
wieder super wieder ein überfahren
natürlich standard ich schreibe das sei
mit dem smiley genau wir sind schon mal
93 kilometern und freunde und wir haben
die 100 erreicht unitymedia don't like
radlader rabatt livestream nokia-spitze
dann schon wieder ein tollen punkt
bekommen aber ich schau dir mal kam
natürlich schon berlin
das wars mit sex drive mit dem
helikopter 3 passt das wohl noch nie
dieses spiel war behindert
wer von euch hat mir das empfohlen wenn
ihr andere coole spiele kennen schlag in
die kommentare so mini kick ding games
hallo freunde kurzer nachtrag eben zum
video und zwar wenn ihr das video
gesehen habe findet in ein paar stunden
das ich habe gerade meinen drucker mit
meinem ellbogen bock in ein paar stunden
findet dass let's play poker event statt
wo ich auch dabei bin wo max auch dabei
ist schon auf letzter bei peter lässt
dabei die vietoris dabei yukon ist aber
noch viele andere glaube ich da geht es
um guten zweck und das ganze geld
gespendet und mega coole veranstaltung
ich bin der poker miteinander das ganze
jedoch live übertragen ich hab euch die
links zu den live-übertragungen unten in
die video beschreibung der gewinner der
das ganze pokerevent quasi gewinnt kann
nämlich das geld was er damit quasi so
als gewinn geld bekommen hat
spenden und es geht bei mir wieder an
die gemeinde korb zum bielefeld das ist
eine heilsarmee und wollte ich ja letzte
mal schon aber leider verloren die ich
wollte euch nur sagen dass ich dabei bin
und ihr könnt da im livestream mit dabei
sein und mich anfeuern sehen wie ich als
erstes rausfliege und den tisch
zerschlagen
das war kein wird und dann sehen wir uns
da
tschüss